what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and i know everybody's
wondering where that first teaser
trailer is for thor love and thunder
there are a lot of rumors going around
right now about when it could possibly
drop but today we're really going to
break it down to figure out when exactly
this trailer should be coming now rumors
have it that it is coming this month
which makes a lot of sense we have the
entire month of march left for the
trailer to arrive and we're getting
pretty dang close to that july 8th
release date so we're actually gonna do
some math and figure out when other
teaser trailers released and how many
days before the actual movie's release
date they came out then we have to talk
about deadpool ryan reynolds has
promised a deadpool 3 update very soon
and of course with all the rumors about
him appearing in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness going kind of
crazy right now the timing of all of
this is pretty coincidental i'm thinking
deadpool is going to be appearing in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness but again i'll break it all down
in this video and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest marvel
news so as of right now we have
126 days until the premiere of thor love
and thunder on july 8th and in case
you're not watching this video on the
day i put it out today is march 4th so
126 days from march 4th now by previous
marvel standards we should actually
already have the teaser trailer this is
actually the longest that we've had to
wait for a teaser trailer with the
exception of spider-man no way home
spider-man no way homes trailer came out
days before the release of the actual
film now the only thing that is the
exception to this is the incredible hulk
that actually came out 93 days before
the movie released but that was such a
long time ago and for the most part
people kind of don't really count the
incredible hulk movie so we won't really
count it either for our purposes in this
video and as far as spider-man know a
home's release date was concerned and
the release of the trailer obviously
there were some major spoilers for
spider-man noway home and they were
doing whatever they could to keep those
spoilers a secret so that's why they
didn't release the teaser that far in
advance from the movie's release date
now thedirect.com did some math and they
figured out the average amount of days
that were between the very first teaser
trailer of marvel films and their actual
release date and that average is
169 days so marvel studios typically
releases a teaser trailer for a film 169
days before the movie's official release
date that means thor love and thunder
being at 126 days before the movie's
release that means we're overdue for the
trailer but not by that much for example
they released the first teaser trailer
for doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness 135 days before the actual
release so right now thor love and
thunder is only about nine days late so
far and i do personally know that it was
really hard to film thor love and
thunder because of the pandemic i
actually met taikawa tt and got to talk
to him at the eternals premiere i told
him i was really excited about thor love
and thunder and his response to me was
yeah i hope i can finish filming it
sometime soon and that was in september
now that's plenty of time to finish a
film and create a teaser trailer but not
if there were reshoots and perhaps some
other problems that arose due to the
pandemic i don't really know anything
more than what he told me but of course
finishing the filming of the movie would
have an effect on the teaser trailer
however i'm pretty sure they're finished
with the trailer or they're about to be
finished with the trailer right now
rumors are going around and they're just
rumors at the moment but they're going
around that we're going to be getting
the trailer this month and i would say
the same because in 10 days there will
only be 116 days left until the release
date and that will tie with the teaser
trailer release for spider-man no way
home and will only be about halfway into
the month if it goes past that this will
be the shortest amount of time between
the actual teaser release and the actual
release date for the film and although i
know thor love and thunder is going to
be super epic it definitely doesn't have
as many rumors and secrecy surrounding
it that spider-man no way home did so
i'm guessing and it is somewhat of an
educated guess based off of all of this
math and the numbers that we just did
that we will indeed be getting the thor
love and thunder trailer this month i
mean if we don't get it this month
that's only four months until the movie
releases that's typically when we're
getting an actual full trailer or maybe
even a second trailer but fingers
crossed that we don't have to wait that
much longer for it and now on to
deadpool wade wilson the merc with the
mouth who is coming to the mcu now for
those of you who are not aware ryan
reynolds himself is writing deadpool 3
with the molino sisters now at one point
in time ryan reynolds came out and said
that he was taking a break from
filmmaking and of course a lot of us
freaked out because we're like oh dang
deadpool 3 is going to be on hold but
then a while ago kevin feige came out
and said that deadpool 3 does have a
release date he said this in an
interview with comicbook.com and not too
long after ryan reynolds announced his
break he did say that he is indeed still
working on deadpool 3. which was great
news and very recently he said that he's
going to have an update for us very soon
so it seems like deadpool 3 and his
entrance into the mcu is coming along
pretty nicely and here's where i
question the timing of this all it looks
like we're going to be getting an update
for deadpool 3 around the time that
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to be coming out and to
me this is a little bit too much of a
coincidence especially if you consider
all of the rumors about deadpool being
in multiverse of madness now of course
ryan reynolds himself has been asked if
he's going to be in the film and he has
denied it but of course everybody denies
it i think we all remember what happened
with andrew garfield until spider-man no
way home came in
that's an unfair frame
um it was uh yeah i lied to people for a
good two years and i lied to the
internet for two years and it felt great
so we can't really trust him when he
says no i'm not in the film and that's
not his fault he just can't say but the
latest rumors and speculation have it
that ryan reynolds is going to be
entering the mcu through doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness that's how
he gets inside our universe from the fox
universe and i've been talking about
this for a while because i think it
makes perfect sense i think it's the
best opportunity plus not to mention
they're actually already doing this
they're doing it with other fox
characters patrick stewart's professor
xavier is entering the mcu via
multiverse of madness and in case you
missed it patrick stewart did confirm
that he is in multiverse madness that
was his voice and that was the
silhouette of him and it's just the
perfect opportunity a film where you're
exploring different universes is a
perfect way to bring somebody in like
deadpool now you might have heard me say
this before but i think the perfect way
to bring deadpool in is if he randomly
stumbles across a new universe and he
kind of just runs away i can just
imagine deadpool doing his thing all of
a sudden a portal opens up to a
different universe of course he's going
to be curious about what that is it's
deadpool so naturally i would assume he
would go through the portal in which he
would most likely encounter somebody
else or maybe not either way i think it
results in him staying in that universe
whether that's him encountering doctor
strange doctor strange explains
everything and deadpool just simply runs
away or he goes into the universe by
himself and decides to stay there and
not to mention he was hanging out at the
x-mansion at the end of deadpool 2. if
some of these fox x-men are being pulled
into the universe it would make sense
that he would be there and be a part of
that as well in which from there i'm
assuming he would run away if he's
introduced in multiverse of madness to
the mcu which i think is the perfect
opportunity and if they didn't do it a
missed opportunity i really do think
it's going to be about him discovering
that his universe the fox universe which
i believe he'll call the fox universe
because he can break the fourth wall is
not as good as the mcu in which then
he'll decide that that's the universe
that he wants to stay in the mcu and no
matter how he goes about staying whether
that's fighting somebody or simply
running off i believe he's going to stay
but let me know what you think about all
of this in the comments down below when
do you hope we get the teaser trailer
for thor 11 thunder i'm assuming that's
today or tomorrow's what you hope and
what do you think about deadpool making
his entrance to the mcu in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
let me know down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof